let's talk about the new author that has
an agent and now has landed a publishing
deal what should they expect what should
they maybe not hold so tightly be very
flexible with and maybe things that they
should fight for yeah I mean I think
that's going to vary a little bit from
author to author and publishing house to
publishing house I know people have had
horror stories and terrible experiences
I know people have had great ones I've
actually had a fantastic experience with
my publishing house and going into it I
wasn't sure because I had heard so many
stories from other authors that weren't
always positive so I didn't really know
what to expect in terms of what to hold
on to and what not to I you know I
always try not to be too precious about
my work that I can't take notes from an
editor and I just always try to remember
that they're on your team and they're
trying to make your work better of
course I think it's important also to
hold fast to things that are really
important to you so if someone's trying
to alter something about your story but
it just goes against what you really
believe you know you can fight for that
but ideally you're getting into bed with
an editor that really gets your work I
think some of the problems come from
getting into bed with a publishing house
or an editor where they want you to be
something different than what you see
for yourself and for your book so being
on the same page right off the bat will
help in terms of being not too precious
well I mean cover design is a big one I
was lucky enough that my agent got me
approval which I don't think is that
common always so I had some control over
the process but I also didn't have to
use it I loved the book cover that's it
okay yeah I loved it all right off the
bat it was exactly it's so beautiful is
exactly something so I didn't actually
have to use my approval but you know and
I've heard even saying stories like that
Barnes & Noble can get publishers to
change book covers to what they want
which is kind of wild that they have
that much control sometimes and I know
people sometimes are frustrated by that
in terms of what to be Precious about or
not I think when you're coming into
marketing and release I think that you
know there's going to be some reviews
that probably aren't going to be
uniformly positive and that can be from
a
a magazine or a trade publication or a
blogger it can also just be from a
random reader on Goodreads and I think
sometimes you know maybe not taking
those seriously just understanding that
different readers are going to like
books or not like books and that isn't a
reflection on the quality of what you
did you know not every book is for every
reader and I think that you just kind of
being okay with that you know and not
because you know it's very easy to feel
bad or get hung up on negative reviews
and you know you just don't know what
was going through the reviewers mind
maybe they just don't like books that
are in that genre maybe who who even
knows so just kind of not taking any of
that stuff too seriously but I do
advocate authors take an active role in
marketing their books I think too many
authors will find a deal and then kind
of sit back and expect their publishing
house to do everything and the truth is
that they're stretched very thin they
have so many titles a lot of times if
you're a new author and your book isn't
the big superstar book that they're
promoting that time you might not get a
lot of resources or attention so then it
becomes your job to really kind of
advocate and really kind of work for
your book so